[Musique]
tu peux nous dire là ce qu'ils sont
devenus les autres membres de culture
club là le jonway cela le batteur la
suie qui avait fondé le groupe là tous
les mecs de culture club un jeune papa
projet toi qu il joue un tout donne des
groupes différents
moi je me suis mis à jouer en solo à
quoi je sais pas moi je ressentais le
besoin de m'exprimer tu vois que j'ai
besoin d'une plus grande liberté de
parole à chaud là il s'appelle la
boulangerie vit où là c'est quoi la
différence avec ce que tu faisais avant
là tu peux l'expliquer aux gens qui
t'ont pas vu là j'ai appelé ça la bonne
jauge review parce qu'un autre personne
qui chante tu vois quoi il ya plusieurs
personnes qui chantent c'est un peu
comme une commune sous review toi tu
vois je vais à des concerts je trouvais
ça vite ennuyeux toi et je crois qu'on
peut pas y aller juste voir comme ça qui
quand quoi il faut couleurs une variété
quoi tu as c'est un peu comme 14
théâtrale il ya le personnage principal
et puis bonne tu vois quand il ya plein
d'autres personnages et des droits
différents corps at war en lit des
choses c'est de donner toi leur chance à
d'autres gens qui ont beaucoup de talent
mais qui n'ont pas eu la chance de
s'exprimer tu as
il
[Musique]
ce qui importe a tu as et là c'est les
jeunes toi moi j'ai de la chance tu as
tu vois ce qu'il faut à la musique c'est
amuser les jeunes tu vois moi j'ai de la
chance parce que je gagne plein de
pognon là je fais un truc que ça mais
comment dire un naturel tu vois je
chante tu vois quoi je m'éclate comme
laura je pense j'aille travailler des
fois tu as un jour par semaine
l'ivoire des concerts à moi je voudrais
leur donner quelque chose de drôle soit
amusante quoi et puis alain portes a
évidemment que celui-ci soit beau et
c'est vrai qu'un jour les vannes il est
venu droit et ça dit avec c'est quoi la
toile à taux réduits vers eilat et
attiédis everything as you need a dit on
va l'enregistrer
s'il reprises alors tu vas faire plus
des remises ou quoi si on regarde
l'ensemble de ma carrière j'ai écrit pas
mal de shenzhen
j'ai la première en plus ce que je fais
[Musique]
si un tube un mois signe tu veux me
faire maintenant je vais écrire à mon
prochain album toutes les chaînes sont
en jeu dira je commence à travailler de
la boj
tu poses souvent l'époque où tu étais au
tabou avec trop jeune les boveri marie
lenuta oublier tout ça en fait ce
concert invité très spécial tu vois que
parce que c'était anniversaire de la
mort de mon ami marc et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles le show les
bonnes parce que je suis vivant toi et
moi je suis contente d'être nuage
je célèbre la mémoire des gens que je
connaissais jeu au nom de ces gens là je
dois continuer de faire quelque chose de
positif quoique est ce qu'on sera
il était important pour moi parce que ça
fait exactement ce que j'ai perdu ma
meilleure amie et je voulais monter sur
scène et donner tout ce que je pouvais
toi tout le monde a trouvé ça super ton
dernier album s'appelle salt et pourquoi
c'était juste une réflexion sur la
presse britannique j'ai pensé bien que
ça fait à voir avec les camps parce que
si tu vas au daily mirror ou aux jeunes
étudient gp ou feindre une rumeur à
propos des pouilles
il l'achète et 30ml frais
mais non vous savez ce que tu sais qui
tu as fendue au plein de gens faut pour
qu'on les citer tous
look très peace a ramé tu es plutôt sage
à l'intérieur j'ai changé c'est vrai que
quand on a fait un cul l'héroïne on peut
tout faire
ça vous rend très très fort et
s'alarment plus fort mais je ne
conseille à personne de commencer à en
prendre c'est une expérience que je ne
souhaite à personne
ça fait partie de ma vie je n'ai plus
parlé fermé ça fera toujours partie de
mon passé je n'ai pas envie de parler
d'eux les doigts tu n'es pas morts comme
sid vicious et james dean et d'usagé
divine ira peut-être ta vie comme
liberace est ce que j'attendais
oh non ça m'inquiète pas ça n'inquiète
par dt dire que tu finiras dans des
draps de soie et des rosses je trouve
c'est une question stupide
[Musique]
c'est vrai que tu pratiques et le
bouddhisme par coin ça s'est traduit
dans le tas vider tous les jours le
bouddhisme que c'est vraiment la
religion du 21e siècle signe religion
que line côté vachement de fatigue
il faut étudier pour bien comprendre tu
vois quoi mais je me voyais explique
hugo ça toi c'est difficile
est-ce que tu n'es pas maintenant elle
est toxique et du beau désert non que je
suis plus un toxique et par quoi que ce
soit maintenant moi je regrette qu'en
france nous n'ayons plus des rois est ce
que tu es un monarchiste ya plus d'une
reine d'angleterre mon souhait pareil en
france aux jeux l'aiment pas vraiment la
reine d'angleterre m'enfin je la préfère
à éclairer le pen
tu es content avec la monarchie à
l'angleterre a ils sont treize
inoffensif en rien s'engage pas sur les
vraies questions soient séquelles il
parie que tu aimes pokou edith piaf je
pense que c'est quelqu'un d'assez
fantastic ouais tu connais des chansons
non non non rien de rien je ne regrette
rien et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de inler 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu